Mother's Day is coming up of course, just a couple weeks,
and Andy, I hear you started a service to help people
find a special gift for Mother's Day, is that right?
Yeah, I did, Conan, I mean, mothers do so much for us
and it's so important that we honor them
on their special day, take a look.
Every Mother's Day, you wait until the very last minute
then panic and wind up getting mom
a thoughtless, impersonal gift.
Well, now you can save yourself the stress and worry
and pre-order that thoughtless impersonal gift today.
Modest Expectations has a wide selection of gifts
that say, "Obligation met."
With Mother's Day classics like dusty Yankee candle,
mugs with her name almost spelled right,
sticky discount bath sets, Applebee's gift cards,
CVS brand compression socks, pool noodles,
Reba McEntire's signature perfume and more.
Just place the order on our website
and we'll do the rest.
When your mom sees the Modest Expectations box,
she'll know she's about to say...
I'm just glad you remembered.
We hatefully gift wrap each item
and guarantee delivery no earlier than 9pm on Mother's Day.
Any earlier and I wouldn't think it was my kid.
Modest Expectations puts in the bare minimum
for you, so you can get back to your busy life.
Modest Expectations, when you care enough
to do the very least.
He knows I don't have feet anymore.
(audience cheers)
That sketch had some button at the end, didn't it?
Like to leave 'em really feelin' it.